Cheer up, spider-fans; Spider-Man's ejection
from the MCU may be short-lived.
According to a new rumor started by YouTuber
TVO, Marvel Studios' parent company Disney
and Spidey film rights holders Sony Pictures
are back at the bargaining table, trying to
work out the details of a new deal that would
keep the wall-crawler in the MCU for a long,
long time.
"YEAAAAAAH!"
The unconfirmed report says that "inside sources"
at Marvel have given TVO the skinny on new
negotiations between the two studios, who
recently failed to reach an agreement to extend
their shared custody arrangement for Spidey.
Again, we stress that this report is completely
unconfirmed, but it would be pretty exciting
if the rumors are accurate.
According to TVO, the new deal being discussed
would involve no fewer than six feature films
starring current Spider-Man actor Tom Holland,
and an option for a seventh.
Who wouldn't want seven more Spider-films?
One of these as-yet-imaginary features would
serve as a direct sequel to this year's Spider-Man:
Far From Home, and would conclude the story
of Peter Parker's high school years.
An additional three solo vehicles would focus
on Parker navigating the ups and downs of
college life while contending with a growing
array of supervillains.
But wait, there's more.
The other two films proposed in the deal,
according to TVO's anonymous and unconfirmed
sources, would be the fifth and sixth Avengers
movies, which have not yet been announced
by Marvel Studios either.
And in true fan-fiction fashion, these sources
also report that the plan is for one of these
team-up flicks to depict Parker meeting up
with one of his oldest allies: Johnny Storm,
the Fantastic Four's Human Torch.
Is it likely that Marvel and Sony have planned
that far ahead, and those plans won't easily
change?
Not really, but technically, this meeting
would be possible thanks to Disney's recent
acquisition of the film and television rights
to the X-Men and Fantastic Four.
As the youngest member of Marvel's First Family,
Johnny Storm was the first hero to offer counsel
to Spidey when the latter was first embarking
on his crime-fighting career, way back in
The Amazing Spider-Man #3.
During a speech at Peter's school, Johnny
Storm spoke about the virtues of never giving
up.
It was a message that hit home with Parker,
who had just suffered his first humiliating
defeat at the hands of Doctor Octopus.
Inspired by Storm's words, Parker saddled
up for a rematch with Doc Ock - and this time,
he won.
TVO's mysterious sources also offered up one
final tidbit: Marvel has allegedly come back
to the table with a couple of bargaining chips
that would incentivize Sony to get the deal
done.
First, the deal would reportedly stipulate
that Disney, who holds the television rights
to Spider-Man, would allow Sony to move forward
with their TV universe based around the wall-crawler
and his pals.
Chris Miller and Phil Lord, who co-produced
the Oscar-winning animated feature Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse for Sony Pictures Animation,
have been tasked with developing the slate
of live-action series, which presumably are
dead in the water until Disney and Sony hammer
out a new deal.
Second, Disney is said to be interested in
integrating Sony's Marvel Characters, which
include Venom and Morbius the Living Vampire,
into the MCU.
The Tom Hardy-starring Venom was a resounding
commercial success, raking in $856 million
dollars at the worldwide box office.
Considering that Far From Home recently became
the highest-grossing Spider-Man movie ever,
and Sony Pictures' best box office performer
of all time, the idea of folding Venom into
the MCU has to be a tantalizing one.
It would virtually guarantee an even more
stellar global take for the Lethal Protector's
second solo vehicle, which could conceivably
feature Spider-Man next time around.
Once again, and we can't say this enough,
this report is in no way confirmed.
But it's not too difficult to imagine that
talks could begin again.
Fingers crossed that TVO's sources aren't
yanking our webs.
We'll be here to report on any official announcements
that may come down from Marvel and Sony.
Until then, the biggest question remains:
"Peter, you’re still with us?”
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.